Feel like you've seen Mandy from Young Sheldon
before? Maybe you've seen her in other sitcoms,
or kids movies, or even a few sitcoms for kids.
In Season 5 of Young Sheldon, viewers
were first introduced to Mandy,
a 30-year-old woman who meets
Sheldon Cooper's older brother
Georgie at the laundromat owned by
the boys' fun-loving grandmother.
While it definitely wasn't love at first sight,
their relationship matures and
Mandy eventually becomes pregnant,
which adds a fun dramatic flare to the sitcom
prequel. Mandy quickly becomes part of the family
with their daughter Constance, who was named
after Sheldon and Georgie's "Meemaw," Connie.
Before taking on the role of the
quick-witted Mandy on Young Sheldon,
Emily Osment — the younger sister of The
Sixth Sense star Haley Joel Osment — was
featured in a few other sitcoms and
even a series of action-packed films.
While she also appeared in her share of
dramatic projects, her performance as
Mandy showcases the comedic acting chops
she's been developing since her youth.
Some of her earliest roles were guest appearances
on 3rd Rock from the Sun and Friends. Her first
truly notable role was in the original Spy Kids
film series, where she portrayed Gerti Giggles.
Rocking unforgettable helicopter pigtails that
allowed the youngster to fly. Gerti debuted
in Spy Kids 2: Island of Lost Dreams, as the
super-spy younger sister of the antagonistic Gary.
She starts as a competitive villain and possible
love interest for protagonist Juni Cortez before
eventually seeing the corruption within her own
family. Osment returned as Gerti for Spy Kids 3:
Game Over, where her fantastical
hairstyle made a fabulous comeback.
She appeared to encourage Juni to take up
the family business as an agent once again.
You might also recognize Osment from her
role as Lilly Truscott on the smash hit
series Hannah Montana. The show became a
worldwide sensation with Osment playing
the best friend of pop superstar Hannah
Montana. Osment's superb sense of comedic
timing shines through as she plays off
series lead Miley Cyrus in a plethora
of laughable situations. She even gets
a chance to play a heightened version of
her character through the clownish alter-ego,
Lola, wearing a variety of bob-cut, neon wigs.
The chemistry between the two
young stars helped propel Hannah
Montana to extraordinary success. Coincidentally,
the two even had their own guest-starring
roles on the raunchy comedy Two and a Half Men.
Emily Osment showed off her goofier side in the
coming-of-age hit Young & Hungry, as the striving
personal chef Gabi Diamond. Contrary to her last
name, things don't always go as smoothly as the
youthful cook would like, leading to a series
of memorable antics. Young & Hungry highlights
the best qualities of Osment's acting history
with slapstick comedy, sarcastic comebacks, and
relatable young adult situations as she navigates
life in San Francisco with her zany friends.
The sitcom was a fresh start for ABC Family as
it transitioned into the trendy Freeform network.
The forward-thinking series helped shift
the landscape towards the new vision with
fellow former Disney Channel star Ashley Tisdale
occupying both a producer role and a recurring
part as a guest star in the series. The two
even shared a few ridiculous scenes together.
"My mom used to do this to
me when I talked too much."
"I just wanted to change the subject."
"Mom never did that."
Osment also lent her talents to the
heartwarming Netflix comedy Pretty
Smart as the snarky brainiac Chelsea. Fans
may even see shades of Sheldon Cooper here,
as her character is extremely similar.
Osment stars as Claire's rigid older sister,
who moves in with her and
her friends in Los Angeles.
The show cleverly balances Chelsea's
overachieving academic life with her
sister's more carefree attitude. At first,
the two seemingly couldn't be more different,
before they inevitably discover their
similarities and grow closer as sisters.
Osment's knack for snarky remarks comes in handy
here as she adapts to the influencer's paradise;
she also captures her character's kinder moments
with authenticity. She even has a romantic
will-they-won't-they relationship with previous
Disney Channel star Gregg Sulkin's character,
Grant, which gives Pretty Smart an added
dose of nostalgia fans will surely enjoy.
Unfortunately, the cozy and colorful
series was canceled after only one season,
though you can still visit this
heartfelt tale anytime on Netflix.